TV creates kind of an immortality for
its actors that can seem surreal so it
can be jarring to learn that certain
stars of the small screen have died with
that in mind here are some sitcom actors
who you may not have known it passed
away from 1986 to 1990 NBC fell in love
with Alf a fuzzy smart-mouthed alien
from the planet melmac who occasionally
tried to eat the family cat the father
of that family was Willie Tanner played
by max right he was the straight man -
the wisecracking Alf puppet an
experience that eventually soured him
enough that he reportedly didn't bother
saying goodbye to anyone on his last day
of work on the series in 1995 Wright was
diagnosed with lymphoma which went into
remission after radiation and
chemotherapy treatments his work was on
the decline after Alf
but after his diagnosis and subsequent
remission he started to find joy again
in 2000 he told People magazine I came
back to life after being on the edge
with a tremendous gusto for the things I
love among other things right landed a
regular gig on the Norm Macdonald sitcom
norm and received a Tony nomination for
his work on the Anton Chekhov play even
off unfortunately writes lymphoma didn't
stay in remission and he succumbed to
the disease in 2019 at the age of 75
Lisa Robin Kelly is best known for her
role as Lauri Foreman on That 70's Show
for the first five seasons she played
Eric's older sister but in the sixth
season she was replaced by Christina
Moore in 2012 Kelly told ABC news that
alcoholism was the reason for her
departure and she also said that our
alcohol abuse began after she suffered a
miscarriage as she explained it I had
lost the baby as a result of that I lost
it I lost everything and I was abusing
alcohol at the time Kelly said that she
was ready for a comeback but
unfortunately that wasn't in the cards
from 2010 to 2013 she had a number of
run-ins with the law she was charged
with driving under the influence in 2010
and in 2013 she was arrested for DUI
again when she reportedly parked her car
on california's i 5 freeway blocking the
lane traffic she was also arrested for
some violent crimes she was charged with
corporal injury upon a spouse in March
2012 and that November both she and her
husband Robert Joseph Gilliam were
arrested after an alleged domestic
disturbance Kelly's battle with
addiction didn't end well she died
shortly after checking into rehab in
August 2013 the Los Angeles County
Coroner deem that her death was due to
combined drug intoxication in an
the dental overdose she was 43 John
Ritter was a staple of American TV for
decades best known as Jack Tripper on
the long-running sitcom Three's Company
he didn't slow down after that show
where its spin-offs ended in the late
80s he helped coin the term dramedy with
the ABC show Cooperman in the early 90s
he led the political satire hearts of
fire a senatorial aide John Hartman he
also had memorable film appearances like
1996 oscar-winning Slingblade
Ritter's final role was protective
father Paul Hennessy on the ABC sitcom 8
simple rules in September 2013 while
rehearsing for the show he was taken to
the hospital after vomiting and
complaining of chest pains initially he
was treated for a heart attack but it
was later discovered that he had a tear
in his aorta
he died during surgery a week shy of his
55th birthday wasn't supposed to happen
mom not now when we were old and gray
and living someplace warm
Shelley Morrison enjoyed a long fruitful
acting career including regular
appearances as sister see snow on the
Sally Field starring 60s sitcom The
Flying Nun but the role she became best
known for wouldn't come until 1999 with
the season 1 finale Will & Grace rosario
is mentioned as early as the series
premiere but we don't actually meet her
until the season 1 finale when karen
gets jacked to marry rosario so she
won't be deported rosario wasn't meant
to show up beyond that episode but she
proved to be popular enough to stick
around while she works as Karen's made
over the course of the series that's
eventually revealed that she has a
degree in clinical psychology performed
with Jennifer Lopez and somehow rakes in
three hundred and fifty thousand dollars
per year Morrison was asked to reprise
the role for the 2017 Will & Grace
revival but by that point she had
retired from acting for good in December
2019 news broke that she had passed away
from heart failure after a brief illness
at the age of 83 Rosie and I would do
other normal couple things you know like
get into a fight at IKEA while he died
much too young Merlin Santana had a
decade's long career in sitcoms in the
early 90s he played the recurring role
of Stanley boyfriend of Rudy Huxtable on
The Cosby Show shortly after his
character Marcus proved to be one of the
most popular parts of getting by a
short-lived sitcom about two single
mothers and their children Merlin's last
big regular sick
spot was as young ladies man Romeo
Santana on The WB's The Steve Harvey
Show that show ended in 2002 the same
year that Santana was killed in his car
in Los Angeles he was only 26 years old
when he was shot in the head by a man
named Damien Andre gates who apparently
erroneously believed that Santana had
been making advances toward his
girlfriend Gates was sentenced to three
consecutive life sentences plus 70 years
in prison for killing Santana and for
attempting to kill fellow actor Brandon
Quinton Adams who was in the car with
Santana during home improvements eight
seasons one of the most popular
characters was also it's least visible
with his face always obscured usually by
offense Earl hyneman's Wilson W Wilson
jr. doled out Yoda like wisdom to the
tool obsessed Tim Taylor audiences
didn't get to see Wilson's entire face
until the series finales curtain call
though in the meantime the show
occasionally had fun with the audience
by showing the bottom half of his face
but not the top Heinemann had been
working in film and TV since the 60s
mainly in smaller roles his big screen
credits include the 1981 military school
drama taps and the 1985 westerns
Silverado before home improvement he was
best known as Detective lieutenant Bob
Reed on the soap opera Ryan's Hope four
years after home improvement ended the
man behind Wilson had to give another
goodbye in December 2003 Hindman died of
lung cancer at the age of 61 well it's
not the only thing he ever did Gary
Coleman will always be remembered for
the role of Arnold Jackson on Diff'rent
Strokes Arnold was the younger of two
Harlem born brothers taken in by
successful businessman Phillip Drummond
Todd bridges played Arnold's older
brother Willis the namesake of Coleman's
classic catchphrase Lewis Coleman dealt
with severe health issues his whole life
while he was adamant about not publicly
sharing specifics it is known that his
short stature was due to kidney disease
he underwent at least two kidney
transplants that were ultimately
unsuccessful a year before his passing
he had heart surgery after which he was
seriously ill with pneumonia while
nothing has been made officially public
it seems likely that one or more of
these issues ultimately led to Coleman's
death he passed away in 2010 after
falling down the stairs in his home and
hitting his head he'd suffered a number
of seizures in the preceding months and
it's believed that those seizures may
have been what caused the fall the
injury eventually led to a brain
hemorrhage from which he didn't recover
and while that story line is too
familiar a famous kid struggling to find
way as an adult only to die young each
time it's just as tragic years before
Will Smith was punching out aliens he
was better known as half of the hip-hop
duo DJ Jazzy Jeff and The Fresh Prince
that Fame helped him eventually bridge
the worlds of hip-hop and acting with
the NBC sitcom The Fresh Prince of
bel-air Smith played a fictionalized
version of himself who sent to live with
his aunt and uncle in the Los Angeles
neighborhood bel-air after a
confrontation with a violent gang over
the course of the series James Avery
would become one of the most well-loved
father figures on American TV as Smith's
Uncle Phil
besides Fresh Prince Avery was also
known for his exceptional voice work he
was the voice of shredder in the
original Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
animated series and of James Rhodes aka
war machine in the 90s iron man cartoon
as for his live-action work he didn't
have too many huge roles besides Uncle
Phil in a 2007 interview with the New
York Film Academy he was candid about
missing out on the spotlight saying you
can either be a movie star or an actor
I'm an actor but I've done pretty good
Avery died in December 2013 due to
complications from open-heart surgery he
was 68 in the first four seasons of the
80s sitcom growing pains Andrew Koenig
played boner best friend - Kirk
Cameron's Mike Seaver his character left
the show in season four to drop out of
college and joined the Marine Corps
gained exacting work after growing pains
wasn't extensive though he had some
other memorable claims to fame it was
the son of Walter caning best known as
the original Chekov on Star Trek
Andrew Koenig also starred in one of the
most famous fan films of all time he
played the Joker and Batman dead end in
which the Dark Knight finds himself
facing the Xenomorphs from the alien
films as well as the ruthless hunters
from the predator franchise in the 90s
and 2000's candy became an outspoken
activist and gained notoriety in his
efforts to draw more attention to
China's support to the military
dictatorship ruling Burma in 2008 he was
arrested for interrupting Pasadena's
rose parade by blocking a float
advertising the Beijing Summer Olympics
and holding up a sign that said China
free Burma in February 2010 canings body
was found hanging from a tree in
Vancouver's Stanley Park his father
confirmed at a press conference that his
son had taken his own life he later
wrote on his website that Andrew died
after a long battle with depression and
urged other depression sufferers to
reach out for help
David Strickland's acting career was
tragically short in the 90s he had
popular recurring roles on the sitcom
sister-sister and mad about you in 1996
he was tapped for the part he'll forever
be known for young eager rock reporter
Todd on the Brooke shield starring
suddenly Susan behind the scenes
Strickland suffered from mental health
and substance abuse issues his suddenly
Susan co-star nestor carbonell told
People magazine in 1999 if he had an
episode where he fell off the wagon it
would be once every two months sometimes
once every six months he'd have a bad
episode and we'd all worry about it for
a night or two and it resurfaced as if
nothing had happened
it always resurfaced Strickland was
reportedly off his prescribed medication
and upset about much of his role in the
1999 rom-com forces of nature being left
on the cutting room floor when he and
Andy Dick flew to Las Vegas in March
1999 the pair reportedly bounced from
strip club to strip club partying hard
and on March 22nd Strickland was found
in his motel room Reid hanged himself
with a bedsheet the writers of suddenly
Susan decided to have art imitate life
in the season 3 finale Todd's co-workers
panic when he goes missing they tell
stories about him interspersed with
clips of out of character interviews
with a cast the episode ends with the
police calling to report his fate which
is left ambiguous if you or anyone you
know is having suicidal thoughts please
call the National Suicide Prevention
lifeline at 1-800 to 73 talk 8255